Imagine you go for a hike and come across a cabin.
It looks interesting, so you decide to explore.
But as you grow closer, you notice something strange.
You hear the sound of your favorite song in the background.
When you open the door, you see shoes and a jacket fitted perfectly for you.
On the table, you see the books and magazines you like to read.
In the refrigerator, you notice your favorite snacks.
And in the bathroom, you find all the toiletries you normally use.
Everything you need to survive tailored just to your liking is there.
How did the cabin get arranged so precisely as it is?
Maybe you just got lucky and all of this is a matter of coincidence.
But that doesn't seem very reasonable if you think about it for a minute, does it?
I mean, there's just too many things tailored precisely for you.
You might not know why, you might not know who did it, but clearly there's some
purpose and design behind the arrangement of this cabin.
Freeman J. Dyson, a renowned theoretical physicist, once said, as we look out
into the universe and identify the many accidents of physics and astronomy that have
worked to our benefit, it almost seems as if the universe must in some sense have
known that we were coming. The laws of physics and astronomy all exist within a very
small range to allow the universe to support life.
It's as if these laws exist on a razor's edge and the slightest change to the left
or the right and the entire universe becomes inhospitable to life.
When I was in college, some friends of mine lived on the third story of an
apartment building with a window overlooking a parking lot, tall row of trees, big
water gutter, and then a stop sign.
And they thought it'd be entertaining and funny to open up their window, use one of
those huge water balloon launchers and launch balloons to try to hit cars as they
came home. Well, one evening we were sitting there and we launched one from the
window. It cleared the water gutter, the trees, the parking lot and hit a car right
on the windshield and cracked it and yes we had to pay for it
imagine how many factors we had to get right to hit our target for example what if
there was more water in the balloon we wouldn't have gone far enough but if there was
less water we would have gone too far what if we're up in the mountains where there's
different air pressure that would have gone further what if the tension in the
launcher was different there's all these things we had to get right to hit our
target well that's not too different from our universe as a whole you see the
universe has been expanding at a very carefully and calibrated rate since its
inception but if that rate were different in comparison with the mass density or
with the dark energy then we couldn't even have a universe that's capable of
supporting life so what are the mathematical odds that a universe with its
laws of physics and cosmology randomly generated being capable of having stars
which are necessary for there to be life. Well, according to astrophysicist Lee Smolin,
the odds are 1 times 10 to the 229th power. You realize how big of a
number that is that's one with 229 zeros after it essentially that's
equivalent to taking every single proton in the entire universe and each of those
protons would represent its own universe with laws of physics randomly
generated mathematically speaking if that were the case none of these universes
would be capable of generating stars which means it wouldn't be capable of having
life but let's compare this to our cabin what if you were blindfolded in this cabin
And you were trying to find a lost coin.
What are the odds that you could find it?
what if we expanded it to the city that I'm in or to the country or
to the entire planet or how about our solar system?
What about our galaxy? What if we expanded it to the entire universe?
What are the mathematical odds that blindfolded you could find this coin?
you realize that it is far more likely far more likely you would find this coin
than we would find ourselves in a universe with randomly generated laws capable
of supporting complex life there's very little debate that our universe is
exquisitely fine-tuned the question is what best explains the fine-
tuning one option people often say is chance but I think we've seen clearly
mathematically that this is not a reasonable explanation.
Another option people say is law.
Maybe there's some law that requires the other laws to be fine-tuned for life,
but the problem is is that laws in physics and cosmology tend to create things that
are simple and repeatable, not complex and specified like we see in the laws that
govern our universe. One final option often used to explain away fine-tuning is
called the multiverse which is the idea that either there's a ton of universes out
there or an infinite number of universes therefore we shouldn't be surprised that we
happen to find ourselves in a universe fine tuned for life well there's a couple
problems with appealing to this to explain away fine tuning one problem is that
there's no direct scientific evidence for the multiverse at this stage it's
scientific conjecture but even if we do find evidence for the multiverse, this
wouldn't explain away design. In fact, all it would do is move design away from this
universe to the multiverse. There would still need to be an explanation for why
there is a multiverse that generates individually fine-tuned universes.
So think about it this way. If we're trying to explain away design of a car and
somebody says, oh, we can explain away by a factory, you'd say wait a minute.
there still needs to be a sufficient explanation for the factory.
Rather than law, chance or the multiverse explaining away fine-tuning,
I think the best explanation is that there is a fine tuner who organized the
universe with us in mind. Just as the arrangement of the cabin pointed towards
somebody expecting our arrival, the exquisite fine-tuning of life
best points towards someone expecting us to live here and even to feel at
home.